e
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
retrouvez moi quand j'étais au pays que
j'aime à dire il fallait dix travaux
grand bien comme tu sais il te prête du
footing
tu vas voir c'est si cela réussit ici
arrêtez vos claviers et stupide écoutez
moi c'est comme les petits
j'ai fini mon tout est un oui c'est city
qui dit de toi tu vas aller avec cela et
tais toi tu parles tu vas aller avec
ceux-ci prévenir mais le coeur qui
viennent me disent faire mieux compris
allez le latin pour danser ça c'est
parti regardez notre mannequin
d'abord le pérou ont annoncé de ramener
le pied droit au rattrapage avait déjà
compris
oui alors j'avance le pied droit je
saute sur le pied gauche de peur ce
trait sur un club où vous êtes dans
votre institut aller montre moi ton pas
encore eu tout est ici alors poussez
vous je vais dans cette lancée m en
longueur où vous croient comme doc brown
et traductions legrois ya qu'un me
demande n'est ce pas mais ouistiti alors
ne vous accompagne de maladroit punirait
pas bougé pouvait mais qu à manier mais
c'est moi je juste bon tels que nouveau
teint qui vont s'étendre d'un le voyage
chattam et regardait ce toujours là
présent à kate est atteint
et voilà et oui président égyptien
allait faire autre chose
atop ben voilà c'est aujourd'hui ça
c'est démodé à 4 bulletins blancs
je vois là et c'est déjà fait c'est
quelqu'un que l'on sait tricot qui j'ai
déjà vu c'est du vin au bout j'étais sûr
vu 6-7 7-6 stupide et joël sa grande
encore souffert mais j'ai déjà vu c'est
très facile ça où nous enverrons moins
besoin pour meilleur tu me déçois tu ne
sais rien faire
montre moi quelque chose de nouveau de
bézieux je veux que tu me fasses sortie
de rire et les cessionnaires vous
oh oh oh le nom comment à moi une année
s'est écoulée
je suis renversé a dû laisser partir un
mois pour en composants selon elle n'y a
qu'à ne neigeait suffisait c'était bien
celui ci était très réussi oui très
nouveau après c'est une autre histoire
[Applaudissements]